खास अवसर, एक बहुत ही गौरवपूर्ण अवसर, एक
बहुत ही भावनात्मक मौका
भी उन सभी जवानों के लिए, उन सभी जांबाजों
के
लिए जिन्होंने राष्ट्र प्रेम की अनोखी
मिसाल पेश की है। अनोखी अनगिनत गाथाएं
लिखी
हैं। भारत के सैन्य इतिहास में वीरता और
बहादुरी के उदाहरण भरे पड़े
हैं। आतंकवाद विरोधी अभियानों में भारतीय
सेना की विशेषज्ञता से राष्ट्रीय सुरक्षा
और भी मजबूत बनकर उभरी
है। गणतंत्र मंडप में
तीनों सेनाओं के प्रमुख उपस्थित हैं। चीफ
ऑफ डिफेंस स्टाफ जनरल अनिल चौहान, थल सेना
अध्यक्ष जनरल उपेंद्र द्विवेदी, नौसेना
प्रमुख एडमिरल डी के त्रिपाठी और वायुसेना
अध्यक्ष एयर चीफ मार्शल एपी
सिंह प्रथम पंक्ति में उपस्थित हैं।
तीनों सेनाओं के वरिष्ठ अधिकारी गण रक्षा
मंत्रालय के वरिष्ठ अधिकारी जिसके
तत्वावधान में इस रक्षा अलंकरण समारोह का
आयोजन होता है और आज जिसका पहला चरण
यहां राष्ट्रपति भवन के भव्य गणतंत्र मंडप
में आयोजित किया जा रहा
है सभी उपस्थित
जन अपने आप को गौरवान्वित महसूस कर रहे
हैं। राष्ट्रपति भवन के गणतंत्र मंडप में
आगमन हो रहा है। देश के
उपराष्ट्रपति श्री जगदीप धनकड़ और उनकी
धर्मपत्नी डॉ. श्रीमती सुदेश धनकड़
का अभिवादन स्वीकार करते हुए माननीय
उपराष्ट्रपति महोदय
आज का यह रक्षा अलंकरण
समारोह भारतीय सशस्त्र बलों की वीरता
कर्तव्य परायणता असाधारण पराक्रम
शूरवीरता और देश प्रेम को समर्पित
है। राष्ट्रपति महोदया द्वारा आज 33 शौर्य
चक्र और छह कीर्ति चक्र प्रदान किए
जाएंगे। जिनमें सात शौर्य चक्र मरणोपरांत
और चार कीर्ति चक्र मरणोपरांत भी शामिल
हैं। देश के लिए सर्वस्व न्योछावर करने
वाले जवानों के परिजन आज गणतंत्र मंडप में
उपस्थित हैं। जिन्हें राष्ट्रपति महोदया
द्वारा कीर्ति चक्र और शौर्य चक्र प्रदान
किए जाएंगे।
देश के सशस्त्र बलों का
समर्पण, देश की सेनाओं की रक्षा के लिए
उनकी प्रतिबद्धता, उनकी लगातार
तैयारी, देश के लिए सर्वोच्च बलिदान हेतु
तत्पर रहने की गौरवशाली
परंपरा हमें हर पल याद दिलाती है कि हमारी
सीमाएं सदैव सुरक्षित हैं। अभेद्य हैं और
किसी भी दुस्साहस का मुंहतोड़ जवाब देने
में सक्षम
है। हर जीत और उपलब्धि में भारतीय सेना ना
केवल सैन्य उत्कृष्टता का उदाहरण पेश करती
है बल्कि राष्ट्र और उसके लोगों के प्रति
कर्तव्य की गहरी भावना भी दर्शाती
है। वीरता, बलिदान और रणनीतिक प्रतिभा की
कहानियां। आने वाली पीढ़ियों को प्रेरित
करती हैं। वर्तमान पीढ़ी में जोश भरती हैं
जो राष्ट्र के भाग्य को का आकार देने में
भारतीय सेना की महत्वपूर्ण भूमिका को भी
रेखांकित करता
है। कुछ ही समय के पश्चात देश की
राष्ट्रपति और भारतीय सशस्त्र बलों की
सशस्त्र सेनाओं की सर्वोच्च कमांडर भारत
की राष्ट्रपति माननीय श्रीमती द्रोपदी
मुर्मू का गणतंत्र मंडप में आगमन
होगा और वे रक्षा अलंकर देश के इन वीर
सपूतों को प्रदान करेंगी।
राष्ट्रीय सुरक्षा के लिए बाहरी खतरे एक
चिरस्थाई चुनौती है जिसका सामना भारतीय
सेना हमेशा करती आई है। गणतंत्र मंडप में
आगमन हो रहा है देश की राष्ट्रपति माननीय
श्रीमती द्रोपदी मुर्मू का।
[संगीत]
माननीय राष्ट्रपति महोदया आपकी अनुमति हो
तो रक्षा अलंकरण समारोह आरंभ किया जाए।
शत्रु का मुकाबला करने के सिवाय
शौर्यपूर्ण कार्यों के लिए शौर्य
चक्र मेजर वर्तमान में लेफ्टिनेंट कर्नल
विजय वर्मा राजपूत रेजीमेंट 44वीं बटालियन
राष्ट्रीय राइफलल्स
मेजर विजय वर्मा ने वर्ष 2021-22 के दौरान
जम्मू कश्मीर में अपनी सेवाएं देते हुए 10
आतंक विरोधी अभियानों में अद्भुत शौर्य का
परिचय दिया जिसमें 22 कट्टर आतंकियों को
मार गिराया गया। अक्टूबर 2022 शोपिया जिले
में चलाए गए एक तलाशी एवं घेराबंदी अभियान
में आतंकियों ने उनके दल पर ग्रेनेड के
साथ हमले के साथ अंधाधुंध गोलीबारी करते
हुए भागने का प्रयास किया। अपने साथियों
को खतरे में देखे शूरवीर अधिकारी निडरता
से आगे बढ़े एवं भीषण गोलीबारी के बीच
बेहद नजदीक से एक आतंकी को मार गिराया।
इसी बीच पड़ोस के एक अन्य गांव से आतंकी
गतिविधि की सूचना मिलने पर उत्कृष्ट
सामरिक सूझबूझ के साथ अपने दल का एक बड़ा
हिस्सा वहां भेजा जिसके फलस्वूप एक और
आतंकी को मार गिराया गया। अनुकरणीय
नेतृत्व क्षमता एवं उत्कृष्ट सामरिक कौशल
के लिए आपको शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया
जाता है। मेजर वर्तमान में लेफ्टिनेंट
कर्नल विजय वर्मा
[प्रशंसा]
उप कमांड विक्रांत कुमार 203 कोबरा
बटालियन केंद्रीय रिजर्व पुलिस बल
2 अप्रैल 2023 झारखंड के चतरा जिले में
मौबादियों के बारे में मिली खुफिया
जानकारी के आधार पर चलाए गए एक नक्सल
विरोधी अभियान में उप कमांड विक्रांत
कुमार को आईडी क्लीयरेंस का जिम्मा सौंपा
गया। एक्सप्लोसिव डिवाइस के निरंतर खतरे
एवं विद्रोहियों द्वारा किले बंद ठिकानों
से निरंतर की जा रही गोलीबारी के बीच आप
अपने दल के साथ विद्रोहियों के अत्यंत
निकट पहुंच गए। लगभग 50 मिनट की भीषण
गोलीबारी के बाद पांच खतरनाक विद्रोहियों
को मार गिराया गया एवं आधुनिक हथियारों का
बड़ा जखीरा बरामद हुआ। साथ ही एक घायल
विद्रोही नेता को गिरफ्तार किया गया। इस
प्रभावी एवं चुनौतीपूर्ण अभियान के
फलस्वूप कई माओवादियों द्वारा आत्मसमर्पण
भी किया गया एवं स्थानीय सुरक्षा में
अत्यधिक सुधार हुआ। असाधारण बहादुरी एवं
अनुकरणीय कर्तव्य निष्ठा के लिए आपको
शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है।
उपकमांड विक्रांत कुमार
[प्रशंसा]
इंस्पेक्टर जे फ्री हमिंग चुल्लू 203
कोबरा बटालियन केंद्रीय रिजर्व पुलिस
बल इंस्पेक्टर जेफ्री हमिंग चुल्लू ने भी
2 अप्रैल 2023 को झारखंड के चतरा जिले में
चलाए गए जोखिम पूर्ण नक्सल विरोधी अभियान
में भाग लिया। विद्रोहियों के ठिकाने की
तरफ़ बढ़ रहा उनका दल अचानक किलेबंद
माववादियों द्वारा की जा रही भारी
गोलीबारी की चपेट में आ गया। उबड़ खाबड़
इलाके की चुनौतियों से जूझते हुए आईडी
विस्फोट तथा विद्रोहियों की अंधाधुंध
गोलीबारी के बीच आमने-सामने की लड़ाई में
आपके दल ने जवाबी हमला करते हुए बेहद
नजदीक से दो बांवादियों को मार गिराया। इस
अभियान में पांच विद्रोहियों के शव, ए के
राइफलल्स तथा अन्य हथियार बरामद किए गए
एवं कई विद्रोहियों द्वारा उच्च स्तरीय
आत्मसमर्पण भी किया गया। अद्भुत बहादुरी
तथा उत्कृष्ट सामरिक कौशल के लिए आपको
शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है।
इंस्पेक्टर जेफ्री हमिंग चुल्लू
[प्रशंसा]
विनंटर वन एंड डेसबिन कीन वायु सेना मेडल
उड़ान पायलट भारतीय वायु सेना।
वर्ष 2022-23 में आप Jaguar स्क्वाडन में
तैनात थे। 24 जुलाई 2023 जग्वार लड़ाकू
विमान की गगनभेदी उड़ान के दौरान आपने
देखा कि विमान अचानक दोनों इंजन की तेल
प्रणाली में आई गंभीर खराबी की चेतावनी दे
रहा था। ऐसे हालात में कीमती इंजन को
बचाने के लिए इसका बंद करना अत्यंत आवश्यक
था। उच्चतम व्यावसायिक कौशल का परिचय देते
हुए आपने केवल बाएं इंजन को बंद किया तथा
दाहिने इंजन द्वारा विमान को निकटतम हवाई
पट्टी की ओर उतारना शुरू किया। 2500 फीट
पर दाहिना इंजन भी भयावह रूप से विफल हो
गया और विमान घनी आबादी क्षेत्र में एक
शक्तिहीन ग्लाइड की तरह नीचे गिरने लगा।
ऐसे जानलेवा हालात में विमान से कूदने की
स्वतंत्रता होने के बावजूद इस जांबाज वायु
योद्धा ने अपनी जान हथेली पर रखकर विमान
को सुरक्षित उतारा। इस प्रकार अपने देश के
बहुमूल्य लड़ाकू विमान को बचाते हुए आम
नागरिकों के जान माल पर आए संभावित संकट
को भी निरस्त किया। उत्कृष्ट उड़ान कौशल
एवं असाधारण साहस के लिए आपको शौर्य चक्र
से अलंकृत किया जाता है। विंग कमांडर
बर्नन टेस्टबिन
[प्रशंसा]
की स्कॉटन लीडर दीपक कुमार उड़ान पायलट
भारतीय वायु सेना
साल 2023 के दौरान आप लड़ाकू विमान
प्रशिक्षण बैंक में अनुदेशक के पद पर
कार्यरत थे। 25 अगस्त 2023 की घोर अंधेरी
रात में आपको किरण वायुयान के एक
प्रशिक्षु पायलट के साथ उड़ान भरने का
चुनौतीपूर्ण जिम्मा सौंपा गया। जो ही
विमान ने उड़ान भरी एक पक्षी के टकराने से
इंजन में आग लग गई। इन विषम परिस्थितियों
में जब लैंडिंग गियर ऊपर जा चुका था।
वायुयान को नीचे उतारना बेहद चुनौतीपूर्ण
था। अद्भुत मानसिक संतुलन का परिचय देते
हुए आपने लगभग 1000 फीट के शेष रनवे पर
वायुयान को सुरक्षित उतारा। रात के घने
अंधेरे में जानलेवा हालात के बीच वायुयान
को फोर्स लैंड करने के दिलेर निर्णय से
बहुमूल्य राष्ट्रीय संपत्ति के साथ-साथ
जान माल के नुकसान को भी बचाया जा सका।
असाधारण उड़ान कौशल अद्भुत साहस के लिए
आपको शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता
है। स्क्वाडन लीडर दीपक
[प्रशंसा]
कुमार स्पेशल पुलिस ऑफिसर अब्दुल लतीफ
जम्मू और कश्मीर पुलिस
श्री अब्दुल लतीफ जम्मू कश्मीर के रियासी
जिले में एक विशेष पुलिस अधिकारी के रूप
में तैनात हैं। सितंबर 2023 के दौरान आपने
उच्च कोटि की सूझबूझ, संयम एवं शौर्य का
परिचय देते हुए एक विदेशी आतंकी का सफाया
करने में महत्वपूर्ण योगदान दिया। अद्भुत
संकल्प शक्ति राष्ट्र प्रेम एवं
शौर्यपूर्ण कृत के लिए आपको शौर्य चक्र से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। स्पेशल पुलिस
ऑफिसर अब्दुल लतीफ
[प्रशंसा]
सूबेदार संजीव सिंह जसोटिया पांचवी पी
बटालियन जम्मू और कश्मीर
राइफल्स आप बारामूला जिले में नियंत्रण
रेखा के समीप एक एंबुश पार्टी कमांडर के
रूप में तैनात थे। कुछ दूर स्थित एक नाले
के पार चार सशस्त्र आतंकियों की
गतिविधियों की सूचना मिलने पर आपने उच्च
सामरिक कौशल का प्रदर्शन करते हुए
आतंकियों को अपनी तरफ बढ़ने दिया। आश्चर्य
को बरकरार रखते हुए आपने आतंकियों को
चुनौती दी। दोनों ओर से की जा रही भीषण
गोलीबारी के बीच आप रेंगते हुए आगे बढ़े।
व्यक्तिगत सुरक्षा की चिंता ना करते हुए
आपने एक आतंकी को मार गिराया एवं दो और
भाग रहे आतंकियों को घायल कर दिया।
अद्वितीय साहस एवं सामरिक कौशल के लिए
आपको शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता
है। सूबेदार संजीव सिंह जस
[प्रशंसा]
रोटिया कर्नल पवन सिंह ट्रिपल6 आर्मी
एिएशन स्कॉडन रेकी एवं
ऑब्जरवेशन 10 अक्टूबर
2023 कल पवन सिंह को कारगिल सेक्टर में
माउंट नोन के कैंप से एक पर्वतारोही
अभियान दल के साथ हुए गंभीर हादसे की
सूचना मिली जिसमें घायल सदस्यों की हालत
निरंतर बिगड़ती जा रही थी। 19,000 फीट से
भी ज्यादा ऊंचाई पर स्थित यह एक ऐसा इलाका
था जो हेलीकॉप्टर की शक्ति सीमा से परे
था। असाधारण व्यावसायिक कौशल एवं अधम्य
साहस का परिचय देते हुए आपने विमान का वजन
कम करने के लिए दरवाजे, सीट, जीवन रक्षक
किट यहां तक कि ऑक्सीजन सिलेंडर तक हटा
दी। प्राणघातक परिस्थितियों में आपने
सफलतापूक एक लो हो तकनीक द्वारा अभियान दल
के सदस्यों को सुरक्षित निकाला। लह जमाती
ठंड एवं ऑक्सीजन की कमी से शरीर शिथिल
पड़ने के बावजूद आपने कुल 14 सदस्यों के
बचाव का मार्ग प्रशस्त किया। अनुकरणीय
कर्तव्य निष्ठा एवं उत्कृष्ट उड़ान कौशल
के लिए आपको शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया
जाता है। कर्नल पवन सिंह
[प्रशंसा]
नायब सूबेदार वर्तमान में सूबेदार पी पबिन
सिंघा द रेजीमेंट ऑफ आर्टलरी 56वीं
बटालियन द राष्ट्रीय
राइफल्स सन 2023 में कुपवाड़ा जिले में
नियंत्रण रेखा पर तैनात सूबेदार दार पी
पबिन सिंघा पांच आतंकवादियों द्वारा
संभावित घुसपैठ की जानकारी के आधार पर
घुसपैठ विरोधी अभियान में एक घात दल का
नेतृत्व कर रहे थे। तकरीबन सुबह 10:00 बजे
पांच आतंकवादियों को देखा गया। त्वरित
कारवाई करते हुए आपने उन पांच आतंकवादियों
को घेरना शुरू किया। किंतु आतंकवादियों ने
भारी गोलाबारी और ग्रेनेड्स के साथ आपकी
टीम पर हमला किया। अपनी टीम पर आसन खतरे
को भांपते हुए आपने अपनी सुरक्षा की परवाह
न करते हुए आतंकवादियों की अंधाधुंध
फायरिंग का सटीकता से जवाब दिया और एक
आतंकवादी को मार गिराया। अतः नायब सूबेदार
वर्तमान में सूबेदार पी पबिन सिंघा को
असाधारण वीरता दृढ़ साहस कुशल नेतृत्व का
प्रदर्शन करने हेतु एवं एक कट्टर आतंकवादी
को मार गिराने के लिए शौर्य चक्र से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। सूबेदार पी पबिन
सिंघा
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर साहिल रंधावा द रेजीमेंट ऑफ आर्टिलरी
34वीं बटालियन द राष्ट्रीय
राइफल्स नवंबर 2023 को शोपिया जिले के एक
गांव में पांच आतंकवादियों की मौजूदगी की
सूचना प्राप्त हुई। तभी मेजर साहिल ने
सावधानी पूर्वक योजना बनाई और लक्ष्य
स्थान की घेराबंदी शुरू करने की
जिम्मेदारी संभाली और सभी आतंकवादियों के
भागने के प्रयास को विफल किया। उसी बीच
आतंकवादियों ने अंधाधुंध गोलीबारी कर
घेराबंदी तोड़ने का प्रयास किया।
अपने साथियों पर खतरे को भांपते हुए आपने
आतंकवादियों की गोलाबारी का बड़ी सटीकता
से जवाब दिया। आपने आतंकवादियों के समीप
पहुंचकर भी धैर्य बनाए रखा और गंभीर खतरे
का बड़े साहस से सामना किया। अपने कुशल
नेतृत्व, अदम्य साहस और अद्वितीय शौर्य का
परिचय देते हुए आपने एक आतंकवादी को मार
गिराया। अपने कर्तव्य की सीमा से पार
विशिष्ट वीरता उत्कृष्ट कार्यशैली एवं चार
सफल ऑपरेशन के संचालन के दौरान प्रेरक
नेतृत्व का प्रदर्शन किया जिसके परिणाम
स्वरूप मेजर साहिल रंधावा को शौर्य चक्र
से सम्मानित किया जाता है। मेजर साहिल
रंधावा
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर वर्तमान में लेफ्टिनेंट कर्नल सीवीएस
निखिल 21वीं बटालियन द पैराशूट रेजीमेंट
स्पेशल
फोर्सेस सन 2000 2023 में मेजर वर्तमान
में लेफ्टिनेंट कर्नल सीवीएस निखिल को
भारत म्यांमार सीमा के पास संभावित घुसपैठ
द्वारा खतरे को विफल करने के लिए सावधानी
पूर्वक योजनाबद्ध घात लगाने का नेतृत्व
सौंपा गया। निगरानी करते समय उन्होंने और
उनके स्काउट ने अपने घात स्थल को तोड़ने
का प्रयास कर रहे सशस्त्र कार्डर्स के एक
समूह की पहचान कर उन्हें चुनौती दी। एवं
दुश्मन की अंधाधुंध गोलीबारी का दृढ़ता से
सामना किया। शूरवीर अधिकारी ने अपनी
व्यक्तिगत सुरक्षा की परवाह ना करते हुए
विद्रोहियों से डटकर मुकाबला किया और उनके
मार क्षेत्र में फंसा दिया। भारी गोलाबारी
के बावजूद आपने असाधारण निशानेबाजी, साहस,
अनुकरणीय फील्ड क्राफ्ट का प्रदर्शन करते
हुए सटीकता से विद्रोहियों को मात दी एवं
एक मोस्ट वांटेड विद्रोही को मार गिराया।
अतः आपकी सामरिक प्रतिभा अद्वितीय नेतृत्व
एवं ऑपरेशन कौशलता की गहन समझ से घाटी के
दो कार्डस का सफलतापूर्वक खात्मा हुआ एवं
घुसपैठ का कुप्रयास विफल हुआ। आपको आपके
कर्तव्य के प्रति दृढ़ निश्चय के परिणाम
स्वरूप शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता
है। लेफ्टिनेंट कर्नल सीवीएस निखिल
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर तृप्तप्रीत सिंह 34वीं बटालियन द
राष्ट्रीय
राइफल्स 2024 को शोपिया जिले के एक गांव
में एक आतंकवादी की मौजूदगी की जानकारी
प्राप्त हुई। त्वरित कार्रवाई करते हुए
आपने टीम लीडर के रूप में मिशन की योजना
बनाई और अपरंपरागत दृष्टिकोण का उपयोग कर
लक्ष्य स्थान की घेराबंदी की एवं आतंकवादी
की ओर बढ़े। इसी बीच आतंकवादी ने आप पर
गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी। परंतु शूरवीर
अधिकारी ने अपने प्राणों की परवाह ना करते
हुए आतंकवादी के बेहद निकट पहुंचकर अपने
अद्वितीय शौर्य का परिचय देते हुए इस
आमने-सामने की गोलाबारी में अपने निपुण
निशाने से उस आतंकवादी को मार गिराया
जिसकी पहचान ए प्लस कैटेगरी आतंकवादी के
रूप में की गई। इसके अतिरिक्त आपने छह सफल
ऑपरेशंस में नौ कट्टर आतंकवादियों को भी
मार गिराया। आपके अदम्य साहस, धैर्य एवं
उत्कृष्ट वीरता का प्रदर्शन किए जाने के
लिए आपको शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया
जाता है। मेजर तृप्तप्रीत सिंह
[प्रशंसा]
लेफ्टिनेंट कमांडर कपिल यादव, भारतीय
नौसेना। 26 जनवरी 2024 को लेफ्टिनेंट
कमांडर कपिल यादव ऑपरेशन पीओजी के दौरान
जहाज पर सहायक इंजीनियर ऑफिसर के रूप में
कार्यरत थे। लगभग रात 10:00 बजे मिसाइल
हमले से लगी भीषण आग के बाद अत्यधिक
ज्वलनशील नेप्था ले जा रहे तेल टैंकर एमवी
मालिन लुआंडा से प्राप्त संकटकालीन कॉल का
जवाब दिया। अग्निशमन विशेषज्ञता के अभाव
में जहाज के मास्टर ने तत्काल सहायता
मांगी और शूरवीर अधिकारी ने अत्यधिक खतरे
के बावजूद जहाज पर चढ़ने के लिए स्वेच्छा
से कार्य किया। अत्यधिक ज्वलनशील और
जहरीले पदार्थ नेपथा जिससे सांस लेने पर
गंभीर श्वसन संबंधी समस्याएं पैदा हो सकती
है। आपने अपनी व्यक्तिगत सुरक्षा की परवाह
न करते हुए जानलेवा परिस्थितियों के बीच
आपने इंजन टैंक के छेद को बंद किया जिससे
ऑक्सीजन की आपूर्ति बंद हो गई। अतः इस
वीरतापूर्ण कार्य और तकनीकी विशेषज्ञता का
अद्वितीय उदाहरण प्रस्तुत किया जिसके फल
स्वरूप लेफ्टिनेंट कमांडर कपिल यादव को
शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है।
लेफ्टिनेंट कमांडर कपिल यादव
[प्रशंसा]
श्री लखवीर डिप्टी कमंडान श्री राजेश
पंचाल सहायक कमंडान श्री मलकीत सिंह
सिपाही जीडी केंद्रीय रिजर्व पुलिस
फोर्स दिनांक 30 जनवरी 2024 को 201 कोबरा
केंद्रीय रिजर्व पुलिस फोर्स ने नक्सलियों
के गढ़ माने जाने वाले टेकलग गुडियम थाना
जगरगुंडा जिला सुमा छत्तीसगढ़ में एक नया
फॉरवर्ड ऑपरेटिंग बेस स्थापित करने के लिए
एक अभियान शुरू किया। जब 201 कोबरा कमांडो
ने नए फॉरवर्ड ऑपरेटिंग बेस की घेराबंदी
की तो उन्होंने हथियार बंद नक्सली को आगे
बढ़ते हुए देखा। त्वरित कारवाई करते हुए
श्री लखवीर डिप्टी कमांडान ने अपनी टीम को
सतर्क किया और श्री राजेश पंचाल सहायक
कमंडान एवं श्री मलकीत सिंह सिपाही जीडी
के साथ नक्सलियों द्वारा भारी गोलाबारी का
सटीकता से जवाब दिया। किंतु इसी बीच श्री
लखवीर गंभीर रूप से घायल हुए। घायल होने
के बावजूद अपने अदम्य साहस एवं कुशल
नेतृत्व का परिचय दिया। साथ ही श्री राजेश
पंचाल के हाथ पर एवं श्री मलकीत की छाती
पर गोली लगने से वे दोनों भी गंभीर रूप से
घायल हुए। इसके बावजूद आप सब ने अतुलनीय
साहस का परिचय देते हुए नक्सलवादियों को
मार गिराया। अतः अपनी विशिष्ट बहादुरी,
असाधारण साहस, अद्वितीय निर्भीकता,
उत्कृष्ट रणनीति एवं सामरिक विशिष्टता का
उत्तम उदाहरण प्रदर्शित करने के लिए श्री
लखवीर डिप्टी कमांड, श्री राजेश पंचाल,
सहायक कमांडान, श्री मलकीत सिपाही जीडी को
शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है।
श्री लखवीर डिप्टी कमांडान
श्री राजेश पंचाल सहायक
[प्रशंसा]
कमंडान श्री मलकीत सिपाही जीडी
जी सूबेदार मोहन राम 20th बटालियन रिचार्ज
रेजिमेंट जनवरी 2024 में सूबेदार मोहन राम
मणिपुर के एक संवेदनशील गांव में तैनात
थे। इस दौरान दो नजदीकी गांव में सशस्त्र
उपद्रवियों ने आम नागरिकों के नरसंहार और
आग लगाने की कोशिश की। सूबेदार मोहन राम
के नेतृत्व में सेना की एक टुकड़ी आम
नागरिकों को बचाने जैसे ही पहुंची
उपद्रवियों ने भारी गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी।
इस भीषण गोलीबारी के बीच सूबेदार मोहन राम
को पैर में गोली लग गई और वे गंभीर रूप से
घायल हो गए। अपनी गंभीर चोट अत्यधिक
रत्स्राव के बावजूद उपचार से इंकार करते
हुए सूबेदार मोहन राम ने 38 निर्दोष आम
नागरिकों की जान बचाई। मृत्यु को परास्त
करते हुए विपरीत परिस्थितियों में अदम्य
साहस, कुशल सैन्य नेतृत्व और शौर्य को
परिभाषित करने के लिए सूबेदार मोहन राम को
शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है।
सूबेदार मोहन राम।
कमोडोर शरद
सिंसनवाल इंडियन
नेवी कमोडोर शरद सिंसनवाल ने 16 दिसंबर
2023 से एडिन की खाड़ी में अपने युद्धपोत
आईएएस कोलकाता का नेतृत्व करते हुए
समुद्री डाकुओं के मिसाइल हमलों में 67
लोगों को बचाया और 17 बंधकों को मुक्त
करवाया। 22 फरवरी 2024 को बैलेस्टिक
मिसाइल हमले से प्रभावित मर्चेंट वेसल
आइलैंडर की सुरक्षा सुनिश्चित करते हुए
चिकित्सा दल भेजा। 4 मार्च 2024 को आपने
दो हूं बैलस्टिक मिसाइलों के हमले से एक
मर्चेंट वेसल पर लगी आग बुझाने का सराहनीय
प्रयास किया। 6 मार्च 2024 को मर्चेंट
वेसल ट्रू कॉन्फिडेंस पर मिसाइल हमले के
बाद खराब मौसम और समुद्री तूफान के बीच 17
लोगों को बचाया। 13 से 15 मार्च 2024 के
दरमियान कमोडोर शरद सिंसियाल के नेतृत्व
में आईएएस कोलकाता ने अप्रित मर्चेंट वेसल
रूेन को बचाते हुए 40 घंटों के भीषण
समुद्री युद्ध में सभी बंधकों को बचाया और
35 समुद्री डाकुओं को आत्मसमर्पण के लिए
मजबूर कर दिया। इन सभी घटनाओं के परिणाम
स्वरूप अंतरराष्ट्रीय समुदाय द्वारा भारत
की विशेष प्रशंसा की गई। कठिन
परिस्थितियों में वीरता, त्वरित निर्णायक
क्षमता और अनुकरणीय सैन्य नेतृत्व का
प्रदर्शन करने के लिए कमोडोर शरद
सिंसुनवाल को शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया
जाता है। कमोडोर शरद सिंह सुनवाल।
[प्रशंसा]
फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट अमन सिंह हंस फ्लाइंग
पायलट 28 मार्च 2024 को फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट
अमन सिंह हंस युद्ध अभ्यास गगन शक्ति के
दौरान एक मिग 29 एयरक्राफ्ट का संचालन कर
रहे थे। 28,000 फीट यानी जमीन से करीब 8.5
कि.मी. की ऊंचाई पर अचानक कॉकपिट में हुए
एक धमाके से सभी हेड अप डिस्प्ले तथा
यंत्रों ने काम करना बंद कर दिया और विमान
की कैनोपी खुल गई और फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट
अमन सिंह हंस अपने एयरक्राफ्ट के साथ
माइनस 40° सेल्सियस के तापमान में बर्फीली
हवाओं के बीच थे। खुद पर नियंत्रण रखते
हुए फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट अमन सिंह हंस ने
आपातकालीन रेडियो से संपर्क स्थापित किया
और इमरजेंसी लैंडिंग की घोषणा की। आंखों
में गंभीर दर्द के साथ हेड डाउन यंत्रों
और बिना कैनोपी के विमान को संचालित करते
हुए फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट अमन सिंह हंस ने
सिविलियन एयरक्राफ्ट से उचित दूरी बनाए
रखी और मृत्यु को पराजित करते हुए नजदीकी
एयरबेस पर सुरक्षित इमरजेंसी लैंडिंग की।
कठिन परिस्थितियों में भी उच्च श्रेणी की
विमान संचालन दक्षता, लौह मनस्व धैर्य और
उत्कृष्ट वीरता तथा त्वरित निर्णायक
क्षमता को व्याख्यान्वित करने के लिए
फ्लाइट लेफ्टिनेंट अमन सिंह हंस को शौर्य
चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है। फ्लाइट
लेफ्टिनेंट अमन सिंह हंस
[प्रशंसा]
सार्जेंट दाभी संजय हिप्पा भाई भारतीय
वायु
सेना 4 मई 2024 को एक रडार यूनिट में
तैनाती के दौरान सार्जेंट डा संजय हे भाई
यूनिट के एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव कॉन्वॉय में
सिक्योरिटी ड्यूटी कर रहे थे। इस दौरान
आतंकवादियों ने कॉन्वॉय पर अचानक एंबुश कर
दिया और भारी गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी। दाहिने
हाथ में गोली लगने तथा हाथों और चेहरे पर
विस्फोट के छर्रे लगने से
अप्रभावित सार्जेंट डाज हिप्पा भाई ने
आतंकवादियों पर तुरंत जवाबी फायरिंग शुरू
कर दी। उनकी प्रभावी फायरिंग के परिणाम
स्वरूप आतंकवादी आगे नहीं बढ़ पाए।
सार्जेंट डाज हिप्पा भाई ने गाड़ी में
मौजूद सभी जवानों की रक्षा करते हुए
आतंकवादियों के हमले को विफल कर दिया। ऐसे
अनुकरणीय युद्ध कौशल, वीरान्वित वीरता तथा
सैन्य कुशलता का प्रदर्शन करने के लिए
सार्जेंट डाज हिप्पा भाई को शौर्य चक्र से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। सार्जेंट डाज
हिप्पा भाई
मेजर कुणाल सेना सेवा कोर फर्स्ट बटालियन
द राष्ट्र
राइफल्स 6 मई 2024 को मेजर कुणाल जम्मू
कश्मीर के एक आतंकवादग्रस्त इलाके में
कंपनी कमांडर के तौर पर तैनात थे।
आतंकवादियों की उपस्थिति के बारे में एक
संवेदनशील खुफिया जानकारी प्राप्त होने पर
मेजर कुणाल ने एक कॉडन एंड सर्च ऑपरेशन
शुरू किया और आतंकवादियों के भागने के सभी
रास्तों को काट दिया। इस दौरान
आतंकवादियों ने भीषण गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी
जिसमें लगभग 150 आम नागरिक भी खतरे में आ
गए। नागरिकों की सुरक्षा को सुनिश्चित
करते हुए और अपने प्राणों की परवाह ना
करते हुए मेजर कुणाल भाली गोलीबारी के बीच
जमीन पर रेंगते हुए आतंकवादियों के ठिकाने
तक पहुंचे और आतंकवादियों के साथ भीषण
नजदीकी लड़ाई में कई निर्दोषों के नरसंहार
के लिए जिम्मेदार एक तुरदांत आतंकवादी को
मार गिराया। सराहनीय नेतृत्व क्षमता,
उत्कृष्ट युद्ध कौशल और असाधारण वीरता का
प्रदर्शन करने के लिए मेजर कुणाल को शौर्य
चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है। मेजर
कुणाल मेजर आशीष दहिया द कोर ऑफ
इंजीनियर्स 50थ बटालियन द राष्ट्र राइफल्स
मेजर आशीष दैया ने पांच विभिन्न आतंकवाद
विरोधी अभियानों में चार खूंखार
आतंकवादियों को मारने में तथा तीन आईईडी
को निष्क्रिय करने में विशेष भूमिका निभाई
है। जून 2024 में मेजर आशीष दहिया जम्मू
और कश्मीर के आतंकवादग्रस्त इलाके में
तैनात थे। इस दौरान एक गांव में
आतंकवादियों की उपस्थिति के बारे में
गुप्त सूचना के आधार पर मेजर आशीष दहिया
ने अपनी टीम के साथ सर्च ऑपरेशन शुरू कर
दिया। छुपे हुए आतंकवादियों ने मेजर आशीष
दहिया की टीम पर भीषण गोलीबारी शुरू कर
दी। जिससे उनका साथी गंभीर रूप से घायल हो
गया। घायल साथी को सुरक्षित करते हुए मेजर
आशीष दहिया भीषण गोलीबारी के बीच
आतंकवादियों तक पहुंचे और दीर्घकाल से
वांछित एक ए प्लस प्लस कैटेगरी के
दुर्दांत आतंकवादी को मार गिराया। असाधारण
वीरता, अद्भुत रण कौशल और अनुकरणीय सैन्य
नेतृत्व का प्रदर्शन करने के लिए मेजर
आशीष दहिया को शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित
किया जाता है। मेजर आशीष दहिया
[प्रशंसा]
हवलदार प्रकाश तमांग नौमी गोर्खा राइफल्स
32 बटालियन द राष्ट्रीय राइफल्स
जून 2024 में हवलदार प्रकाश तमांग एक
कॉम्बैट टीम कमांडर के तौर पर जम्मू और
कश्मीर में तैनात थे। इस दौरान उन्हें
आतंकवादियों के बारे में गुप्त सूचना
प्राप्त हुई। त्वरित कार्यवाही करते हुए
हवलदार प्रकाश कमांग ने अपनी टीम के साथ
एक योजनाबद्ध तरीके से सर्च ऑपरेशन शुरू
किया। तलाशी के दौरान आतंकवादियों ने
ऑपरेशन टीम पर भीषण गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी।
हवलदार प्रकाश तमांग ने अपनी टीम के साथ
जवाबी फायरिंग की। तभी एक गोली हवलदार
प्रकाश तमांग के दाहिने पैर पर लगी और वे
गंभीर रूप से घायल हो गए। अपनी व्यक्तिगत
सुरक्षा की परवाह ना करते हुए हवलदार
प्रकाश तमांग आगे बढ़ते रहे और एक दूरदांत
आतंकवादी को नजदीकी लड़ाई में मार गिराया।
मृत्यु को पराजित करते हुए प्रेरणादायक
सैन्य नेतृत्व विलक्षण वीरता और प्रबल
युद्ध सामर्थ्य के लिए हवलदार प्रकाश
तमांग को शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया
जाता है। हवलदार प्रकाश तमांग
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर सत्येंद्र धनकड़ द आर्मेड कोर फोर्थ
बटालियन द राष्ट्र
राइफलल्स जून 204 24 में मेजर सत्येंद्र
धनकड़ जम्मू कश्मीर में एक कंपनी कमांडर
के तौर पर एक आतंकवाद विरोधी अभियान का
नेतृत्व कर रहे थे। घने दुर्गम और अभेद्य
जंगल के बीच स्थित एक ढोक में आतंकवादियों
की मौजूदगी संबंधी सूचना प्राप्त होते ही
मेजर सत्येंद्र धनकड़ ने लक्ष्य क्षेत्र
की सघन समन्वित और सुव्यवस्थित घेराबंदी
आरंभ की। घेराबंदी का आभास होते ही
आतंकवादियों ने ऑपरेशन टीम पर अंधाधुंध
गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी। स्थिति की गंभीरता
को भांपते हुए मेजर सत्येंद्र धनकर ने
अत्यंत सटीक और निर्णायक प्रतिक्रिया दी
और पहले आतंकवादी को मार गिराया। भीषण
गोलीबारी में अपने साथी सैनिक पर खतरे को
भांपते हुए उन्होंने निस्वार्थ भाव से
अपने साथी को सुरक्षित किया और स्वयं भीषण
गोलीबारी के बीच खुली स्थिति में आ गए। इस
दौरान एक गोली उनके पैर को छूती हुई
निकली। रणनीतिक निर्णय क्षमता का प्रदर्शन
करते हुए मेजर सत्येंद्र धनकड़ भारी
गोलीबारी के बीच रॉकेट लांचर ऑपरेटर तक
पहुंचे और रॉकेट लांचर का प्रयोग करते हुए
कुल तीन विदेशी आतंकवादियों को मार
गिराया। रणभूमि में प्रदर्शित अतुलनीय
संयम, विवेकशील, सैन्य नेतृत्व और असाधारण
वीरता को परिभाषित करने के लिए मेजर
सत्येंद्र धनकड़ को शौर्य चक्र से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। मेजर सत्येंद्र
धनकड़।
[प्रशंसा]
सहायक कमांडेंट एशथंग की फॉर असम
राइफल्स मणिपुर में एक संवेदनशील क्षेत्र
के निकट उपद्रव्यों की गतिविधियों के बारे
में विशिष्ट खुफिया जानकारी प्राप्त होने
पर सहायक कमांडेंट एशथंग की नेतृत्व में
एक विशेष टीम का गठन किया गया। अगस्त 2024
में 12 सशस्त्र उपद्रवियों द्वारा आम
नागरिकों को प्रताड़ित करने की सूचना
मिली। स्थिति की गंभीरता को भांपते हुए
सहायक कमांडेंट एशथंग किकोन ने त्वरित
प्रतिक्रिया दी और रणनीतिक घेराबंदी कर
सभी निकास मार्गों को अवरुद्ध कर दिया। इस
दौरान स्वचालित हथियार चलाने का प्रयास
करते एक सशस्त्र उपद्रवी को सहायक
कमांडेंट एशथंग किकोन ने सटीक फायरिंग से
अक्षम कर दिया। सराहनीय सामरिक कौशल का
प्रदर्शन करते हुए सहायक कमांडेंट एशथंग
की ने सभी 12 उपद्रवियों को गिरफ्तार कर
पांच हथियार बड़ी मात्रा में गोला बारूद
तथा युद्ध सामग्री बरामद की। भारी भीड़ के
बीच युद्ध स्थल से गिरफ्तार उपद्रवियों की
सुरक्षित निकासी के साथ ही घायल उपद्रवी
को चिकित्सीय सहायता मुहैया कराई और
क्षेत्र में आंतरिक सुरक्षा की स्थिति को
पूर्णतः नियंत्रण में किया। कर्तव्य के
प्रति अत्यम निष्ठा अप्रतिम साहस और
अनुकरणीय सैन्य नेतृत्व के लिए सहायक
कमांडेंट ऐशंत की कोण को शौर्य चक्र से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। सहायक कमांडेंट
ऐशथंग की कोण।
सूबेदार विकास तोमर फर्स्ट बटालियन द
पैराशूट रेजीमेंट स्पेशल
फोर्सेस जम्मू कश्मीर के दुर्गम और अति
संवेदनशील इलाके में अनेक सैन्य अभियानों
का नेतृत्व कर चुके सूबेदार विकास तोमर को
घने जंगल में स्थित एक ढोक पर निगरानी का
महत्वपूर्ण दायित्व सौंपा गया। असाधारण
सामरिक समझ, भौगोलिक बारीकियों पर पकड़ और
आतंकवादियों की हरकतों का गहन विश्लेषण
करते हुए सूबेदार विकास तोमर ने अपनी टीम
के साथ ढोक की घेराबंदी की। तभी
आतंकवादियों ने अचानक तीव्र और भीषण
गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी। सूबेदार विकास तोमर
ने लौह मनस्वी धैर्य और रणभूमि पर कुशलता
प्रदर्शित करते हुए जवाबी फायरिंग की और
अपने साथियों को सुरक्षित किया। अपने
प्राणों की परवाह ना करते हुए सूबेदार
विकास तोमर भीषण गोलीबारी और खराब मौसम के
बीच आतंकवादियों के ठिकाने तक रेंगते हुए
पहुंचे और एक दुर्दांत आतंकवादी को नजदीकी
लड़ाई में मार गिराया। रणक्षेत्र में
प्रबल युद्ध प्रवीणता, विलक्षण वीरता और
दृढ़नायक सैन्य नेतृत्व को व्याख्यान्वित
करने के लिए सूबेदार विकास तोमर को शौर्य
चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है। सूबेदार
विकास तोमर
[प्रशंसा]
शौर्य चक्र के पश्चात अब कीर्ति चक्र
प्रदान किए जाएंगे। शत्रु का मुकाबला करने
के सिवाय असाधारण वीरता के लिए कीर्ति
चक्र मेजर मल्ला रामगोपाल नायडू मराठा
लाइट इनफेंट्री 56वीं बटालियन राष्ट्रीय
राइफलल्स
मेजर मल्लाराम नायडू कुकवाड़ा जिले में
नियंत्रण रेखा के निकट चलाए गए घुसपैठ
रोधी अभियान में घातक टुकड़ी का नेतृत्व
संभाल रहे थे। आपके स्काउट ने अचानक पांच
आतंकियों को देखा। अपने दल को तुरंत
सुनियोजित करते हुए आपने घात लगाकर
आतंकियों पर हमला कर दिया। चट्टानों की
आड़ लेकर आतंकियों द्वारा किए गए जवाबी
हमले से अपने सैनिकों पर आए खतरे को
भांपते हुए आपने निडरता से आगे बढ़कर एक
आतंकी को मार गिराया एवं दूसरे को घायल कर
दिया। गोलियों के बौछारों के बीच मेजर
नायडू ने अपने सटीक निशाने से आतंकियों को
रोका जिससे तीन और आतंकियों का सफाया हुआ।
तलाशी अभियान के दौरान एक गुफा में छिपे
पांच में आतंकी ने ग्रेनेड फेंकते हुए आप
पर गोलियां बरसानी शुरू कर दी। अद्भुत
शौर्य दिखाते हुए आपने उस आतंकी को भी मौत
के घाट उतार दिया। अनुकरणीय नेतृत्व
क्षमता अिग संकल्प शक्ति के साथ दो कट्टर
आतंकियों को मार गिराने के लिए आपको
कीर्ति चक्र से सम्मानित किया जाता है।
मेजर मल्लाराम गोपाल नायडू।
[प्रशंसा]
मेजर मनजीत पंजाब रेजीमेंट 22 बटालियन
राष्ट्रीय
राइफल्स मेजर मंजीत ने सुपुर जिले में एक
विश्वसनीय सूत्र से मिली सूचना के आधार
दो विदेशी आतंकवादियों की गतिविधियों पर
कड़ी निगरानी रखी। संदिग्ध परिसर को
चिन्हित करते समय आपने एक सशक्त घेरा
स्थापित किया। आपके दल ने रात के अंधेरे
में आतंकियों द्वारा इस रक्षात्मक परिधि
को तोड़ने के कई प्रयासों को सफलतापूर्वक
नाकाम किया। अगली सुबह एक आतंकी ने नजदीक
स्थित बाग में छिपने की कोशिश की। मेजर
मंजीत ने अपनी सटीक गोलीबारी से उसे रोका
तथा वहां फंसे नागरिकों और बच्चों को
सुरक्षित निकालने का साहसिक निर्णय लिया।
भीषण गोलीबारी के बीच आप रेंगते हुए आगे
बढ़े। आपने देखा कि एक आतंकी उनके स्काउट
पर ग्रेनेड से हमला करने की तैयारी कर रहा
है। अिक संकल्प के साथ आपने अपने सटीक
निशाने से उस आतंकी को मार गिराया।
असाधारण वीरता एवं उत्कृष्ट नेतृत्व
क्षमता के लिए आपको कीर्ति चक्र से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। मेजर
[प्रशंसा]
मनजीत अब शौर्य चक्र मरणोपरांत प्रदान किए
जाएंगे। मेजर आशीष ढोंचक सेना मेडल
सिक्लाइट इनफेंट्री 19 राष्ट्रीय राइफल्स
मरणोपरांत सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह सिक लाइट
इनफेंट्री 19 राष्ट्रीय राइफल्स मरणोपरांत
मेजर आशीष ढोंचक सेना मेडल तथा सिपाही
प्रदीप सिंह जम्मू कश्मीर के अनंतनाग जिले
की घनी जंगली पहाड़ियों में चलाए गए एक
आतंक विरोधी अभियान का हिस्सा थे। उनका
खोजी दल जो ही लक्षित ठिकाने के नजदीक
पहुंचा। वहां छिपे आतंकियों ने ताबड़तोड़
गोलियां बरसाते हुए भागने का प्रयास किया।
अपने साथियों को प्राणघातक खतरे में देख
मेजर आशीष अपनी जान की परवाह ना करते हुए
आगे बढ़े तथा अपनी सटीक गोलीबारी से कवर
फायर देते हुए आतंकियों को भागने से रोका।
सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह ने अग्नि स्काउट के
रूप में अद्भुत शौर्य एवं कर्तव्य निष्ठा
का परिचय दिया तथा अपनी जान जोखिम में
डालकर मेजर आशीष के साथ आतंकियों को रोकना
जारी रखा। भीषण गोलीबारी के बीच गंभीर रूप
से घायल होने के बावजूद मेजर आशीष ढोंचक
एवं सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह आखिरी सांस तक
आतंकियों का मुकाबला करते हुए अंततः
वीरगति को प्राप्त हुए। उनके प्रेरणादायक
बलिदान ने उनके दल में नई ऊर्जा का संचार
किया जिससे आतंकवादियों का खात्मा किया
गया। भारतीय सेना की उच्चतम परंपराओं के
अनुरूप सर्वोच्च बलिदान के लिए मेजर आशीष
ढोंचक सेना मेडल तथा सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह
को मरणोपरांत शौर्य चक्र से अलंकृत किया
जाता है। सम्मान ग्रहण करेंगे उनके
परिवारजन।
स्वर्गीय मेजर आशीष ढोंचक सेना मेडल की
धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती ज्योति ढोंचक तथा माता
श्रीमती कमला ढोंचक
[प्रशंसा]
स्वर्गीय सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह की धर्मपत्नी
श्रीमती सीमा
रानी स्वर्गीय सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह की
धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती सीमा रानी
हवलदार रोहित कुमार डोगरा रेजीमेंट हाई
ऑल्टीट्यूड वॉरफेयर स्कूल मरणोपरा
एक उत्कृष्ट पर्वतारोही होने के कारण हाई
ऑल्टीट्यूड वॉरफेयर स्कूल में प्रशिक्षण
के पथ पर तैनात हवलदार रोहित कुमार को 777
मीटर ऊंची माउंट कोन की गगनभेदी चोटियों
पर ऑपरेशन क्लाइंबिंग ट्रेनिंग टीम के
प्रशिक्षण अभियान की जिम्मेदारी सौंपी गई।
18,600 फीट की ऊंचाई पर आयोजित इस
चुनौतीपूर्ण अभियान में हिमस्खलन के खतरों
के बीच गहरी दरारों को लांगते हुए उनका दल
बर्फीले दुर्गम रास्तों पर आगे बढ़ता रहा।
लहू जमाती सर्दी में उनके प्रेरणादायक
नेतृत्व में माउंट कुन की खड़ी पहाड़ियों
पर सुरक्षित मार्ग स्थापित करते हुए 2000
मीटर से अधिक रस्सी को सफलतापूक बिछाया
गया। 8 अक्टूबर 2023 को 85 डिग्री की खड़ी
पहाड़ी पर चढ़ते समय अचानक एक विशाल
हिमशिखल स्थलित हो गई तथा हवलदार रोहित
एवं उनका दल उसकी चपेट में आ गया। बेहद
मुश्किल परिस्थितियों में अपने दल का
अंतिम क्षणों तक हौसला बढ़ाते हुए हवलदार
रोहित कुमार अंततः वीरगति को प्राप्त हुए।
सर्वोच्च बलिदान के लिए हवलदार रोहित
कुमार को मरणोपरांत शौर्य चक्र से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। सम्मान ग्रहण
करेंगे उनकी धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती भारत
लक्ष्मी एवं पूज्य माता श्रीमती कृष्णा
देवी।
[प्रशंसा]
कास्टेबल श्री पवन
कुमार 200 कोबरा बटालियन कास्ट्टेबल श्री
देवन सी 200 कोबरा बटालियन केंद्रीय
रिजर्व पुलिस बल मरणो परात
दिनांक 30 जनवरी 2024 छत्तीसगढ़ के सुखमा
जिले के अंतर्गत नक्सलियों का गढ़ माने
जाने वाले टेकल गुड़ियम इलाके में
केंद्रीय रिजर्व पुलिस बल की 2011 कोबरा
तथा 150वीं बटालियन द्वारा नया नया अग्रिम
ऑपरेटिंग बेस स्थापित करने के लिए एक
चुनौतीपूर्ण अभियान शुरू किया गया। कोबरा
बटालियन के कमांडो ने ज ही इस इलाके की
घेराबंदी शुरू की। नक्सलियों ने बैरल
ग्रेनेड लांचर एवं अन्य हथियारों से अचानक
भारी गोलीबारी शुरू कर दी। इस तीव्र हमले
का मुंहतोड़ जवाब देते हुए अभियान दल ने
तुरंत मोर्चा संभाला। सिपाही पवन कुमार
एवं सिपाही देव सिंह ने अपनी जान की परवाह
ना करते हुए आगे बढ़ रहे नक्सलियों का
डटकर मुकाबला किया। गंभीर रूप से घायल
होने के बावजूद आखिरी सांस तक लड़ते हुए
देश हित में अपने प्राणों का उत्स्र्ग
किया। इस शौर्यपूर्ण अभियान में कई
नक्सलियों को मार गिराया गया। असाधारण
बहादुरी एवं सर्वोच्च बलिदान के लिए
सिपाही श्री पवन कुमार एवं सिपाही श्री
देवन सिंह को मरणोपरांत शौर्य चक्र से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। सम्मान ग्रहण
करेंगे उनके परिवारजन।
पहले स्वर्गीय सिपाही श्री पवन कुमार की
धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती आरती एवं पूज्य माता
श्रीमती शकुन
[प्रशंसा]
देवी स्वर्गीय सिपाही श्री देवन सिंह की
धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती गायत्री एवं उनकी पूज्य
माता श्रीमती सी कस्तूरी
[प्रशंसा]
ओईएम ग्रेनेड वन विजय कुट्टी जी सीमा सड़क
संगठन मरणोपरांत
ओएम ग्रेड वन विजन कुट्टी जी सीमा सड़क
संगठन के कुशल एवं कर्मठ ऑपरेटर थे।
जिन्हें रोड कंस्ट्रक्शन कंपनी के अंतर्गत
दुर्गम इलाकों में सड़क निर्माण एवं
निकासी का विस्तृत अनुभव था। वर्ष 204 के
दौरान आप अपने जेसीबी व्हील लोडर के साथ
जम्मू के नजदीक रियासी माहौर सड़क पर
तैनात थे जो राजौरी पुछ इलाके के लिए
अत्यधिक महत्वपूर्ण मानी जाती है। गहरी
खाइयों वाले इस भूभाग में पत्थरों के
गिरने का खतरा निरंतर बना रहता है। 15 जून
2024 विजय कुट्टी जी का व्हील लोडर अचानक
नियंत्रण खोकर घाटी की ओर लुढ़कने लगा।
अपनी सुरक्षा की चिंता किए बिना उन्होंने
मशीन पर पुनः नियंत्रण पाने का साहसिक
प्रयत्न किया। लेकिन भरसक प्रयासों के
बावजूद जेसीबी ऑपरेटर समेत गहरी खाई में
जा गिरा। सिर में आई गंभीर चोट के कारण
विजन कुट्टी जी वीरगति को प्राप्त हुए।
अद्भुत कर्तव्य निष्ठा एवं सर्वोच्च
बलिदान के लिए ओईएम विजय कुट्टी जी को
मरणोपरांत शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया
जाता है। सम्मान ग्रहण करेंगी उनकी
धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती निशा बी।
[प्रशंसा]
कैप्टन दीपक सिंह सिग्नल कोर 48वीं
बटालियन राष्ट्रीय श्री राइफल्स मरणो
परांत जम्मू कश्मीर के डोडा जिले में
आतंकियों की खुफिया जानकारी के आधार पर
कैप्टन दीपक सिंह के नेतृत्व में दो दलों
को तैनात किया गया। निरंतर निगरानी के बाद
शाम 7:30 बजे आतंकियों की गतिविधि नजर आने
पर कैप्टन दीपक ने अपनी टुकड़े को संगठित
करते हुए आतंकियों की घेराबंदी की एवं
सटीक गोलीबारी से एक आतंकी को घायल कर
दिया। अंधेरा होने एवं आतंकियों द्वारा
चट्टानों के पीछे छिपने की भीषण चुनौतियों
के बावजूद उन्होंने पूरी रात निगरानी बनाए
रखी। अगली सुबह सूरज की पहली किरण के साथ
इस युवा अधिकारी ने एक सुब्यवस्थित तलाशी
अभियान शुरू किया जिसमें एम4 असोल्ट राइफल
एवं गोला बारूद बरामद किया गया। इसी बीच
चट्टानों में छिपे घायल आतंकी ने गोलीबारी
शुरू कर दी। अपने प्राणों की चिंता ना
करते हुए इस जांबाज अधिकारी ने अपने साथी
को सुरक्षित पीछे धकेला और आतंकी की
गोलीबारी का सटीक जवाब दिया। आमने-सामने
की गोलीबारी में गंभीर रूप से घायल होने
के कारण अंततः वह वीरगति को प्राप्त हुए।
अद्भुत पराक्रम, निस्वार्थ, सेवाभाव एवं
सर्वोच्च बलिदान के लिए कैप्टन दीपक सिंह
को मरणोपरांत शौर्य चक्र से सम्मानित किया
जाता है। सम्मान ग्रहण करेंगी। उनके पूज्य
माता श्रीमती चंपा सिंह एवं पूज्य पिता
श्री महेश सिंह गारवी।
शौर्य चक्र मरणोपरांत सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह
सिक्लाइट इनफेंट्री 19 राष्ट्रीय राइफल्स
मरणोपरांत सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह ने अग्नि
स्काउट के रूप में अद्भुत शौर्य एवं
कर्तव्य निष्ठा का परिचय दिया तथा अपनी
जान जोखिम में डालकर मेजर आशीष के साथ
आतंकियों को रोकना जारी रखा। भीषण
गोलीबारी के बीच गंभीर रूप से घायल होने
के बावजूद सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह ने आखिरी
सांस तक आतंकियों का मुकाबला करते हुए अत
अंततः अपने प्राणों का उत्सर्ग
किया। सर्वोच्च बलिदान के लिए स्वर्गीय
सिपाही प्रदीप सिंह
को शौर्य चक्र मरणोपरांत से अलंकृत किया
जाता है। सम्मान ग्रहण कर रही हैं। उनकी
धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती सीमा रानी।
[प्रशंसा]
अब कीर्ति चक्र मरणोपरांत प्रदान किए
जाएंगे। शत्रु का मुकाबला करने के सिवाय
असाधारण वीरता के लिए राइफल मैन रवि कुमार
द जम्मू एंड कश्मीर लाइट इनफेंट्री 63वीं
बटालियन द राष्ट्रीय
राइफल्स तिलाक 12 सितंबर 2023 को राइफलमैन
रवि कुमार एक खोजी अभियान के अग्रणी
स्काउट का कार्यभार संभालने के लिए
स्वेच्छा से आगे आए। दोपहर करीब 3:00 बजे
जब वे अत्यंत दुर्गम एवं घने जंगल वाले
इलाके में आतंकवादियों का पीछा कर रहे थे
तभी उनका सामना दो आतंकवादियों से हुआ।
अपने साथी पर आतंकवादियों द्वारा खतरे को
भांपते हुए उन्होंने अपने साथी को
सुरक्षित किया एवं कवर लेते हुए सटीकता से
जवाबी फायरिंग की। इसी बीच वे एक आतंकवादी
की गोली का शिकार हुए एवं गंभीर रूप से
घायल हुए। इसके बावजूद उन्होंने चिकित्सा
निकासी से इंकार कर दिया और आतंकवादी की
गोलाबारी का बहादुरी से सामना कर उनके
भागने के प्रयास को विफल किया। एवं एक
आतंकवादी को मार गिराया। वे अपनी आखिरी
सांस तक आतंकवादियों की गोलीबारी का
सटीकता से जवाब देते हुए अंततः वीरगति को
प्राप्त हुए। राइफल मैन रवि कुमार को
अधम्य साहस उत्कृष्ट युद्ध कौशलता एवं
अनुकरणीय बलिदान का उदाहरण प्रस्तुत करते
हुए देश सेवा में अपना सर्वोच्च बलिदान
देने हेतु कीर्ति चक्र मरणोपरांत से
सम्मानित किया जाता है। सम्मान ग्रहण
करेंगे उनके पिता श्री सुभाष चंद्र।
[प्रशंसा]
कर्नल मनप्रीत सिंह सेना मेडल 19वीं
बटालियन द राष्ट्रीय राइफल एवं पुलिस
उपाधीक्षक हुमायूं मुजम्मिल भट्ट द जम्मू
कश्मीर पुलिस
दिनांक 13 सितंबर 2023 को कर्नल मनप्रीत
सिंह सेना मेडल को अनंतनाग जिले के एक घने
जंगलों वाली पहाड़ियों में एक विशिष्ट खोज
और विनाश अभियान के नेतृत्व करने का
कार्यभार सौंपा गया। इसी अभियान में पुलिस
उपाधीक्षक हुमायूं मुजम्मिल भट्ट ने भी
स्वेच्छा से विशेष संचालन समूह कॉलम का
नेतृत्व किया। जैसे ही उनकी टीम
आतंकवादियों के समीप पहुंची आतंकवादियों
ने टीम पर अंधाधुंध फायरिंग शुरू कर दी।
अपनी सुरक्षा की परवाह ना करते हुए कर्नल
मनप्रीत सेना मेडल ने बड़ी सटीकता से
जवाबी कार्रवाई करते हुए एक आतंकवादी को
मार गिराया। साथ ही असाधारण नेतृत्व का
प्रदर्शन करते हुए उन्होंने अपनी टीम को
पुनर्गठित किया। किंतु इस भीषण गोलीबारी
में उनके सर पर गोली लगने से वे गंभीर रूप
से घायल हुए और वीरगति को प्राप्त हुए।
इसी बीच पुलिस उपाधीक्षक हुमायूं ने भी
अपनी सुरक्षा की परवाह ना करते हुए बड़ी
बहादुरी से आतंकवादियों की अंधाधुंध
गोलीबारी का प्रभावी ढंग से जवाब दिया और
उन्हें भागने से रोका। परंतु इस जवाबी
कारवाही में वे आतंकवादी की गोली का शिकार
हुए और वीरगति को प्राप्त हुए। अतः कर्नल
मनप्रीत सिंह सेना मेडल एवं पुलिस
उपाधीक्षक हुमायूं मुजमिल भट्ट ने असाधारण
वीरता अद्वितीय कर्तव्य प्रायणता और
अडिक्ट
साहस से लड़ते हुए देश के लिए अपना
सर्वस्व न्योछावर किया। सम्मान ग्रहण
करेंगी कर्नल मनप्रीत सिंह की धर्मपत्नी
श्रीमती जगमीत एवं माताजी श्रीमती मजीत
कौर पुलिस उपाधीक्षक हुमायूं मुजम्मिल
भट्ट की धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती फातिमा अली
नायक दिलवर खान 28 बटालियन द राष्ट्र
राइफल्स नायक दिलबर खान 23 जुलाई 10 2024
को कुपवाड़ा जिले के लोलाब घाटी के घने
जंगलों में घात अभियान का हिस्सा थे। देर
रात उनकी टीम का दो आतंकवादियों से सामना
हुआ। त्वरित कार्रवाई करते हुए उन्होंने
एवं उनकी टीम ने सटीक गोलीबारी शुरू कर
दी। जिससे आतंकवादियों ने उन पर आक्रामक
तरीके से हमला किया। इसी बीच अपनी
व्यक्तिगत सुरक्षा की परवाह ना करते हुए
उन्होंने असाधारण वीरता का परिचय दिया और
भारी गोलाबारी के बावजूद निकट आ रहे
आतंकवादी पर सटीक हमला किया और उसे मार
गिराया। किंतु इसी दौरान दूसरे आतंकवादी
ने उन पर अंधाधुंध गोलीबारी कर उन्हें
गंभीर रूप से घायल किया। अत्यधिक रक्त
स्राव के बावजूद उन्होंने आतंकवादियों की
गोलीबारी का निपुणता से जवाब दिया और
अदम्य साहस का परिचय देकर आतंकवादियों से
लड़ते हुए मातृभूमि पर अपना सर्वस्व
समर्पण कर दिया। उनके अद्वितीय शौर्य,
दृढ़ कर्तव्य निष्ठा, उत्कृष्ट बहादुरी
एवं सर्वोच्च बलिदान के परिणाम स्वरूप
उन्हें कीर्ति चक्र मरणोपरांत से सम्मानित
किया जाता है। सम्मान ग्रहण करेंगी उनकी
धर्मपत्नी श्रीमती जमीला एवं माताजी
श्रीमती भोला बीबी।
[प्रशंसा]
माननीय राष्ट्रपति महोदया आपकी अनुमति हो
तो रक्षा अलंकरण समारोह समाप्त किया जाए।
[संगीत]
भारत के राष्ट्रपति माननीय श्रीमती
द्रोपदी मुर्मू ने देश के लिए सर्वोच्च
बलिदान करने वाले अमर सपूतों को रक्षा
अलंक करण प्रदान
किए। राष्ट्रपति महोदया गणतंत्र मंडप से
प्रस्थान कर रही हैं। अन्य विशिष्ट अतिथि
गण भी गणतंत्र मंडप से रवाना हो रहे हैं।
इसके साथ ही गणतंत्र मंडप में आयोजित
रक्षा अलंकरण समारोह का पहला चरण अब
संपन्न होता है। अनुमति दीजिए। नमस्कार।